das zwei berliner polizisten am
holocaust mahnmal für sechs millionen
ermordete jüdinnen und juden
liegestützen machen ist nicht nur eine
unwiderrufliche schande für sie selbst
und die polizei sondern vor allem auch
ein symbol unsere deutsche realität von
holocaust langeweile 42 der deutschen
meinen heute jüdinnen und juden leben zu
viel darüber was ihn im holocaust
widerfahren ist laut dge gehandelt
studie es gibt fatale lücken in unserer
bildung über den holocaust es fehlt eine
verknüpfung von historischen fakten zu
den persönlichen identifikation und den
individuellen lehren für das heutige
leben dies betrifft die polizei mit
ihrer enormen gesellschaftlichen
verantwortung aber auch eine vielzahl
von anderen menschen nicht zuletzt
zeigen die vielen instagram
fotoshootings und stylischen outfits am
holocaust-mahnmal herrschte holocaust
wie breit gestreut dieses problem ist
meine andere heute hier sie alle haben
tisch haben schon einmal einen
stolperstein in ihrem kiez gesehen
niemand von ihnen kann jedoch einen
namen und eine persönliche persönliche
geschichte hinter einem dieser
stolpersteine auf ihrem kiez heute hier
mit uns teilen holocaust sonntagsreden
reichen auch für sichtlich nicht aus der
stimme ich vollkommen mit überein das
ist das ist ganz ganz wichtig der
holocaust gerät in vergessenheit
und dann müssen wir uns überlegen was
wir da machen die frage ob wir jetzt
einer von uns die geschichte hinter
einem stolperstein erzählen können ist
schwer zu beantworten also ich kann das
halbwegs war vor meiner haustür eine
die szene die sie beschreiben am
holocaust mahnmal ist auch ein problem
dieses mahnmal selbst das haben wir von
anfang an so erlebt das haben wir auch
von anfang an so diskutiert das
holocaust mahnmal ist so aufgebaut und
der der künstler das gemacht hat hat das
bewusst so getan dass man da sozusagen
hineingeht und dann von einer bestimmten
stimmung erfasst wird nun gibt es immer
leute die gehen da hinein und werden von
der stimmung nicht erfasst wir hatten
schon sehen von touristen die haben da
ein picknick draufgemacht auf den stelen
wir hatten andere die haben stehlen
verunreinigt also aber auch nicht
grundsätzlich
hat er aber immer das dann alles keine
leute das waren alles keine leute die
das das mahnmal spenden wollten im fall
der polizisten wissen wir es nicht in
dubio pro reo vielleicht waren sie zu
doof und wussten gar nicht wo sie sind
bei sich ich kann ich jetzt nicht sagen
diese bilder sind
schwierig nur zu sagen vielleicht nicht
aber
zu sagen alle die es an ehrfurcht
mangeln lassen tun das nicht unbedingt
bewusst weil das man mal so ausgebaut
ist dass man da reingeht und wenn man
die nötige vorbildung nicht hat deswegen
wurde übrigens auch irgendwann darunter
also die irgendwann sondern wenig später
nach der eröffnung dieses
dokumentationszentrum noch eingerichtet
ja weil man eben sagte er die menschen
verstehen ja gar nicht was der eisenbahn
wollte
nicht alle die sich da wirklich so
verhalten wie man es auf keinen fall
sollte tun dass absichtlich und da sind
sich operieren sie ein bisschen das
würde ich kritisiere band aber sind
daher schon jetzt sind die polizisten zu
doof also ich würd auch an dieser stelle
mir das so einfach auch wieder nicht
machen
zunächst mal ich habe ganz viele
zuschriften ganz selten viele so viele
zuschriften bekommen wie zu diesem zu
diesem ereignis auch und gerade von
jungen kolleginnen und kollegen die ihre
betroffenheit übrigens teilen ganz
bestimmt und ich würde es auch sehr
richtig und gut dass die barbaras lorig
die polizeipräsidenten von berlin sich
unverzüglich für diesen vorgang
öffentlich entschuldigt hat weil die
richtige geste die vor allem schnell
passiert ist auch wichtig die musste
mich erst darauf aufmerksam gemacht wird
ist auch eine klofrau die frau slowik
das wird uns so einfach machen dürfen
hinter diesem vorfall sozusagen einen
vorsätzlichen bewussten akt zb der
holocaust relativierung zu sehen das
glaube ich nicht ich glaube dass wir
tatsächlich uns die mühe machen müssen
mit dem betreffenden beamten zu sprechen
und zu hinterfragen was sie sich und ob
sie sich überhaupt etwas dabei gedacht
haben
verständlich
wenn sie also wenn sie nicht wussten wo
sie sind das macht das ja ein schlimmer
mache ich mich irgendwie schlimmer ja
stimmen ja zur berliner polizisten nicht
wissen was das holocaust nicht nötig
ich würde es mir allerdings nicht so
einfach machen einfach nur pauschal
geschichtsunterricht für die polizei
zuvor und das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen zu wenig geht dem problem auch
nicht auf den grund denn das sind ja wer
stellt eigentlich die frage danach wie
waren eigentlich die äußerung steht wo
waren eigentlich die vorgesetzten die
frage stellt sich offensichtlich gern
körner gibt es hier
und ich musste das schwein das braucht
auch keine führung die person die ihm
gesagt bitte machen den ich liegestütze
auf 6 mio eur zudem ist die erzeugung
die sind ja nicht alleine diese leute
deshalb ja aber man muss doch trotzdem
die frage stellen wieso ist da
eigentlich niemand der den in dieser
sekunde und zwar schon bei beginn sagt
martic dir eigentlich noch richtig
das waren zwei erwachsene männer und
entweder wir oder sie hat auf jeden fall
es ist eine absolute geschmacklosigkeit
würde auch alle eure uns ein wirklich
glauben ihm aber eine
geschmacklosigkeiten dass es schwieriger
ist also am ende des tages haben sich da
zwei menschen hingestellt und haben
diese liegestützen gemacht was heißt das
für die ausbildung bei der polizei was
heißt das für unsere gesellschaft dass
wir eine große lücke haben nicht nur in
der holocaust bildung sondern was das
auch persönlich für uns bedeutet dass
diese zwei individuen egal ob die
polizisten an oder nichts macht das
schlimmer bei der polizei sind dass
diese zwei individuen keine persönliche
verbindung haben zu dem holocaust und
dass sie das nicht erkannt haben ich
glaube nämlich nicht dass er die
einzigen zwei aber dass sie es nicht
erkannt haben muss jedoch jetzt nicht
verwundern da gibt es doch viele das ist
doch wirklich ein bildungsproblem also
das können wir jetzt nicht bei der
polizei ab lager deswegen sage ich
glaube dass die bilder die wir kennen
hashtag holocaust ein gutes beispiel
sind das durchweg ist wir wissen aber
auch gleich aus schlagen sie konkret vor
ich glaube wir brauchen einen
bildungsplan bei der polizei dass sich
vielmehr damit auseinander selbst was
die eigenen leeren persönlich als
individuum aber auch polizei als
institution aus dem holocaust gibt
es gar nicht funktioniert ist aber das
gibt es ja schon also das können sie
jetzt nicht vor der
ausbildung ist genauso angelegt ist die
sie damit sei es ist auch ein an contis
bei sn wie man mit seinen
voreingenommenheiten umge training hat
auch mit drin das sind ein paar
powerpoint slides und dann hat man keine
vorurteile und voreingenommenheit das
kauf ich also wir müssen und sollte die
staatsbürgerliche bildung in der polizei
noch weiter intensivieren möglicherweise
auch regelmäßig durch fortbildung
ausbauen und wir sollten auch die
vorgesetzten immer weil ich das schon
bin ich sofort bei ihnen die frage ist
müssen allerdings wissen das kostet geld
da braucht man kapazitäten für häufig
ist das thema aus- und fortbildung und
der polizei übrigens kein inhaltliches
thema schon gar kein thema des willens
der einsatzkräfte sondern in der regel
ein kapazitätsproblem die leute haben
schlichtweg gar keine zeit solche fonds
erhält hängt der antisemitismus
beauftragte der polizei in berlin ein
mensch der sehr viel verantwortung auch
für diesen bereich hat arbeitet ja auch
mit rias der institution für
meldestellen von antisemitismus zusammen
ein tolles programm registriert wo es
erstmal um die erkennung von
antisemitismus geht und da hat man ja
eine klare entscheidung getroffen das
ist uns wichtig ich glaube spätestens
nach diesem vorfall muss die berliner
polizei und andere länder 56 mal
dahergesagt muss auch eine entscheidung
treffen sagen das ist uns wichtig wir
nehmen uns die kapazitäten wir nehmen
uns die ressourcen weil wenn wir uns als
deutschland als berlin sagen wir haben
keine kapazitäten um holocaust bildung
hechingen einig darüber dass da nicht
26.000 berliner polizei beschäftigte
liegestütze gemacht haben sondern zwei
und deshalb mit die polizei muss man
immer ein bisschen vorsicht ist aber
auch nicht die journalisten
würden sie denn jetzt als konsequenz für
die beiden fahrern also ziemlich
natürlicher vorgang aufklären
das heißt ich würde mir braucht
vielleicht ein tag einmal nein lautet
das motto weißt dass das so schnell gute
bewahren wenn die sagen wir hatten keine
ahnung wo wir da sind dann sagt man okay
vielleicht noch mal in die
geschichtsbücher gucken oder sich mit
der eigenen stadt beschäftigen die
beamten erwartet doch ohnehin ein
disziplinarverfahren und das dauert ein
bisschen länger als einen tag und dann
wird genau ergründet wo waren die motive
welche entschuldigungs gründe haben sie
möglicherweise vorzutragen dann wird die
person persönlichkeit des einzelnen
beamten mit berücksichtigt und dann wird
im disziplinarverfahren wird dann zu
einer entscheidung kommen und dann haben
wir nicht 20 22 und die sache ist längst
vergessen ein disziplinarverfahren
werden bei der polizei nicht vergessen
sondern dienten bei nachgewiesenen
dienstvergehen mit einer
disziplinarmaßnahme das ist so in der
polizei da gibt es übrigens feste
abläufe mit übrigens auch disziplinar
verteidigern denn auch das gibt es die
beamten nicht nach athen ist ja die
haben ein anrecht darauf
disziplinarverfahren ordentlich
vertreten zu werden das machen unter
anderem die polizei gewerkschaften unter
anderem eine